Marty Millennials that was really good
with the beautiful match my pitch like
almost perfectly because you did it
right before we let live and I just have
pitch matter yes you're syndrome I have
the new app called pitch matter
you had the picture back and some people
up stick it to the man yo sis you have
the pitch master syndrome right do you
want to hit me with another one okay
ready
[Music]
that adds good but still pretty good
pretty good but who are you and we're
playing that game in the street wait we
were at the Seaport waiting for our uber
yeah where we were both singing like we
were like who could sing higher levels
and the Turk has been as a man's voice
oh I'm already at a disadvantage but
obviously I wasn't they put me in a
singing competition and I dare me not to
win except for the talent show at cam
toes oh my gosh also I'm feeling very
self-conscious because literally our
number one fan told me yesterday that
she couldn't watch it yesterday's
episode our mom she said we said like so
many times oh my god I heard this too so
I've never even felt self-conscious of
my likes but now like my own mother I
will be stopping okay I'll try and call
you out but I had no idea
and why was yesterday different from all
other episodes I don't know you were so
physically broken free Minister day that
maybe all we could do was just sit here
and say like look like look like and I
feel as though sometimes we say the l
word when we don't have what to say but
yesterday there was so much to say so I
don't know why we would have said the l
word so many times no I completely agree
and I do feel as if I didn't say like I
do feel as if that sometimes I say the
word totally and as a replacement of
like because like is such a millennial
word that I'm really showing my age when
I say like so many times so I've really
started to amp up the total ease and
that has become like a first taken word
that I can't say anymore
you just I just yeah what I said that is
because like you said that has become
like a first taken word oh my god where
the L words coming in it's not when
you're saying totally you don't say
totally instead of saying like you know
but it's just like a crutch like I look
alike it's just a crutch it is a crutch
also I feel as though sometimes we use
the l word where other people might say
um or uh or take a break I shudder as if
that is true as well so maybe we should
say um or perhaps we should talk slower
however I agree this is this is as if we
are doing an episode of Hooked on
Phonics
yes or rosetta stone rosetta stone I
need to relearn the English language
like from start to finish letters and
everything because I really can't speak
I speak like I speak as though I know
but this is a correct you say I speak
like like like someone who just meant to
this country seriously like and it has
no idea of the language okay well I'm
gonna try and call you out on it today
hopefully we don't say it so much I
never even pay attention anymore whether
I'm saying it or not because I just yes
you just what I just have let go and let
God when it comes to the l word no bye
but I'm going to start paying more
attention you know I just got called out
on it yesterday and I thought that I
would share that information with you so
that maybe we can be a little bit more
cognizant of our vernacular I think this
is a fair assessment of our show every
toast do i well how was your day I feel
like I just saw you ah my day yesterday
but shouldn't believably production
we're out here cranking out content
yesterday like it is our jobs because it
is and the patreon is lit we did an
episode of patreon yesterday that we
gathered questions for last week and it
was an entire in-depth Q&A on our on our
experience at fat camp we had so many
questions people don't know that we
actually did and go to a fat camp when
we were children I wanted what was that
experience like so we did an entire
episode about that and then we also find
the label not wait Jackie finish our
camp toast montage video it is a
tearjerker the song selection premium
it's really just if you want to capture
the essence of Khem toast that video did
just that
yep I couldn't decide between doing a
documentary feature or you know about
Mitzvah style montage so I decided to go
all routes it's very long it's all there
and I hope you all enjoyed it's for its
for your enjoyment it definitely starts
off selling then picks up towards the
end but you know I really wanted to take
you on a journey with us that's also how
Campos like as our first day went was
slow
it picked up at the end and it was just
it was a halleluiah night so if you want
to experience what that means head over
at patreon.com slash the morning toasts
for two premium episodes and that rounds
out the month of May yes we have a few
days off then we'll pick back up in June
with some more premium content someone
just suggested in the comments a great
idea for an episode which is that we
should take like a speech class and like
film it that would be funny because the
teeth the lips the tip of the tongue the
teeth the lips how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chuck wood Peter Piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers pickled peppers how many
pickled peppers did Peter Piper pick
Sally sells seashells by the seashore
that one's a hard it was hard for me
once upon a time duckies have a lisp but
it's true I did have lists I did go to
speech pathology class did you feel when
you were you know back in the lispy days
little iSpy vibes bags only did you feel
marginalized like how did you feel about
your list but like I didn't actually
ever realize like you like where a lisp
well first of all I'm very Pro Lisp in
general I think it's such a cute thing
especially for children it's cute unless
they're like spitting on you yes but in
general when someone has ago a little
bit of a lisp I think it's cute okay so
I was never so concerned with getting
rid of it all so my front teeth hadn't
grown in so that's why I couldn't crack
like why don't they just wait for your
[ __ ] teeth to grow it and then maybe
you gonna save money on the class right
but I had a good time on the bus of
speech pathology we would get on a
little trailer a lot of saliva flying
around we had extra snacks oh that's low
it was pretty late you know we had a
good crew going I really miss being a
child where like every activity was
really surrounded around like the snacks
I feel as if adulthood could use more of
that I've known so adulthood is
surrounded around snacks like even when
you go to work places it's like when are
we having bagels
when are we getting you know snack at
lunch you know everything's surrounded a
dough hook is surrounded about free food
in corporate offices there's like
literally one person whose job it is to
make sure like all the meetings have
snacks yeah and to make sure like the
people don't ride in the streets and
that they get enough free food to say
whew
and you know what it's an important job
it is an important job we need one of
those here yeah yeah I'm hungry well we
did officially hire since yesterday and
she didn't show up so it's looking like
she might not be working out yeah I
don't know we'll have to talk to her
manager yeah love to speak to her
authority authoritarians um well before
we do that and go ahead go ahead and
stitch on snitch Jackie and I are
obviously here to deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast first up you have some
ariana grande news who's been relatively
Wow [ __ ] he's been on tour always talked
about her yes ariana grande postpones
tour dates due to illness ariana grande
has postponed too far to tour dates due
to illness the singer announced on
social media today the shows originally
scheduled for Tuesday at Tampa's Amalie
arena and May 29th at Orlando's my
center will be postponed to November
24th and 25th respectively grande shared
on her Instagram story quote I woke up
incredibly sick today I ran to my doctor
here and have been told to postpone
these shows tonight and tomorrow I'm so
beyond devastated I will make this up to
you I promise please forgive me I love
you and I will be back and better than
ever as soon as possible love you so
whenever anyone no matter who they are
cancels the show except for pink I
always think I'm like something's up you
know like who's on drugs so I don't know
I partied too hard last night who hid
the jewel and can't sing today
who's got the popcorn lung who's got the
bats what it is does she jewel I mean
everyone Jules I mean that's what okay I
learned so many things about myself and
my community at cam toasts but what I
really learned was that every person in
the world Jules yes but I do feel as
though I can't toast um a lot of people
were Julianne because that was sort of
our legacy yeah um but other people were
bringing like dual alternatives as well
so it's like they're even embedded in
the day yes but they knew no other date
machines that are better and they're
less popular yeah and less expensive
well I just want to say you know I've
only been on one tour in my life but I
feel really proud that I've never
canceled the show now I saw the whole
leg coming up so it's possible but I
don't know I'm just like such a hard
worker and they really find a way to
make any story about myself that's sure
I hadn't thought of it and then you know
now
you said it of course knock on wood but
you know you've got ink sirs oh yeah no
I know I mean but here's the thing the
thing is is that I have done I think
three shows this year with strep so it's
like if I did it through that what can I
handle yeah and I guess you are I mean
for her because she really does say that
it's so much physical like movement I
just and it's different than it is that
for other artists who you know have a
back track who rap or just talk their
way through or barely even do that um so
I think her voices is quite pertinent to
the touring situation and at least she's
home in Florida where she can recover I
think she has shown Miami coming up um
which sounds live because she's in her
home state I would want to go to re in
Florida yeah I mean she is technically
from Boca and I would love to see her do
like a bogus show you know really go
down to her roots with all the grannies
playing like tennis but Miami will do
but she hasn't canceled the Miami one
yet right no just Tampa and Orlando so I
believe I believe in cancellation I
don't think there's more to this story I
mean perhaps it was usual situation but
I think she'll be back on her the road
soon you know I have no proof that I
just any time someone cancels a show
like I'm always suspicious but this is
probably nothing no I don't think this
doesn't sound like much so give the girl
a break did you see her [ __ ] wax
figure no I didn't because that wasn't
her that was horrific do you know who it
looked like did you ever see that video
of the guy who did ariana grande 73
questions like to a tee like he started
the whole video he was sitting on a
stool like in the weird way she sits on
stools right outside our house in did
like a whole set of questions he's
having just like her the wax figure
looks more like him than it did her ad
not look like her and they usually don't
really do dropping it's not like she's
so hard to nail down yeah so maybe their
lead wax designer was on vacation or
something yeah or maybe the we let the
wheel ax design the lead wax designers
just like their time is up you know yeah
like it's it's time for a new hotshot to
come in yeah
take over I think so this was a cry for
help it was a cry for help and I love
that Arianna adjusted she added them on
Twitter said we need stuff it's that bad
I know I mean honestly they took what's
so weird about wax figures it's like
sometimes they look so similar that a
person will stand next to him and
in a photo you don't know who the wax
figure is like the Christian or one is
crazy so it's like how did the same
institution make the Christian or wax
figure and the ariana grande wax figure
also we used to ride so [ __ ] hard
from Adam she says like when we were
kids it was like a monthly activity that
we would go to the wax museum and just
like take a million pictures it's like I
have a picture I'm like Bill Clinton's
lap which is like highly inappropriate
yeah oh my god we have to find that and
post it yeah where would we even find
that photo we know where to find them we
got to go through the books in the
basement yeah yeah oh my god that's
hysterical
yeah oh we have the Spice Girls wow that
was like our dream like we really felt
it's actually crazy cuz like now it's
like when I think about a wax museum
like it's like a weird thing where they
make replicas of people when you're a
kid it's like the closest you're gonna
get to that celebrity like you almost
feel starstruck like by this wax figure
so us we were too big it's nice yeah
you're the biggest bicycle fans and I
think we really felt we were out like a
Spice Girls Mean Green when we were like
sex yeah like now objectively like what
is the point of a wax museum like as an
adult I can't understand but as a child
it was like the closest you could really
get to meeting a celebrity yeah weird
weird I don't know I don't know man are
you ready for Story number two so fast
okay yeah I'm just speeding through
because I want to talk about anything to
talk about Game of Thrones because kid
Harrington checked into luxury rehab for
stress and alcohol I heard Game of
Thrones Start Kit Harington secretly
checked into a luxury rehab for stress
and alcohol use ahead of the show's
ending which quote really hit him hard
multiple sources have exclusively
confirmed to page six exhausted have it
sounds like first exhausted it's like
Blake Carrington he's to him rather
exhausted it's exhausting Jon Snow on
the hit HBO series for eight years has
been at luxury Connecticut health
retreat Prive Swiss for nearly a month
arriving weeks before the show's finale
on May 19th the British actor has been
undergoing psychological coaching
practicing mindful meditation and
cognitive behavioral therapy to combat
stress and deal with negative emotions
at the facility which costs over
$120,000 a month
Oh his actress wife Russ
roughly you can't say our name in an
American accent restlessly no it's less
let's see okay I can't even say who has
but it's not rose it's so like how could
you even pronounce that in American
accent Russ Leslie Russ Leslie to the
principal's office
Russ Leslie bro the thing is her name
isn't Rose get you trying to say
Rose Leslie with an American accent
sounds like Lisa Vanderpump imitating
the American women on the show yes Rose
Leslie but her name is it rose it's rose
Russ whose actress right whose actress
wife Russ Leslie he met on the set of
Game of Thrones and played Jon Snow's
wildling companion you read that whole
sentence Jon Snow's wobbling companion
Ygritte is being extremely supportive
we're told okay I should hope so
overall this story is sad but I'm guys
taking the necessary measures and you
know it's not even sad that sounds a
lovely he's been in a world when past
couple of years he needs time to wind
down
he's hitting this local facility 120
grand a month getting premium meals
meditating they probably got him doing I
think you probably got him in his room
doing open fit workouts you know like
he's just getting his mind body and soul
corrected you know no I completely agree
and like I needed to go to rehab after
the end of Game of Thrones I can't
imagine how he feels I just feel like if
the worst thing in the world is me
taking some time off
getting to know my Center you know
finding my soul just like getting back
to a healthy mind body and soul is that
the worst thing in the world
no and I know you're doing it using open
of course I am because open fit takes
all the complexity out of losing weight
and getting fit it's a brand new super
simple streaming service that allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room for as little as 10 minutes
a day everyone's bodies are different
and open fit get set which is why
personalize it is personalized to your
needs and custom tailored original
content we love premium content much
less original content you can forget all
the complexity and stress around getting
fit and just press play and workout on
your schedule
600 seconds with celebrity trainer Devon
Wiggins packs evaporating muscle
building
and body-sculpting benefits of much
longer sessions into a fraction of the
time as someone who was like a lot of
free time but doesn't want to spend a
lot of it working out this really like
feels good
open venous change the way that we work
out and with our code toast you can join
us on a Fritton hour fitness journey to
personalized just for you again use our
code toast and start using open fit for
your journey to a healthier life right
now during the open fit 30-day challenge
our listeners will get a special
extended 30-day free trial membership to
open fit where you can lose up to 15
pounds in 30 days when you text toast to
30 30 30 you will get full access to
open fit all the workouts and
nutritional information totally free
again just text toast to 30 30 30
standard message and data rates may
apply great staff but the Jon Snow thing
everyone was like four we came out like
making it seem like it was such a big
deal like finally somebody's being open
about where they are you know like in
Traverse and wonder why people go to
like rehab and pretend it's like for
their anxiety because there's such a
stigma around thank you for being open
like I probably have an unhealthy
relationship with alcohol too and it
might behoove me to go to a facility and
knowing that Jon Snow did it maybe I'm
not as embarrassed to say yeah I'm the
one-handed saying this is so this is
where we need to have as a society just
to be more honest and open about these
things on the other hand like sometimes
it feels as though there might be more
to this story
but you know what we're getting a piece
of honesty and I appreciate that yeah
also um it also does feel weird it's
like both it's like I do whichever I'm
gonna be open more and more honest but
then at the same time it's like it's
your business like if you want to go get
treated for heroin addiction like that's
not my [ __ ] business
that's true also it doesn't he didn't be
he wasn't open and honest about this
like he went privately and has been
doing this and then someone [ __ ]
snitched and looking rude yeah this is a
page 6 exclusive day that got the scoop
that someone was a snitch we know all
about his [ __ ] cognitive treatments
that is so unethical and it's just like
so yeah I thought he came out and like
said it in an interview no they got the
snitch
okay so we didn't like come out and be
open about honesty but but still I like
I said when no one was wondering where
he was like and I I just assumed he was
in Britain you know yeah I remember
these like they go through something and
then you know once they're o through it
then they talk about it and then they're
honest but once they're able to be
honest about it but the cool way to
Japan get that opportunity who are we to
demand like every single celebrity like
opens up and tells us about their
deepest darkest demons
like that probably will hinder their
progress in these types of facilities so
I changed my mind I take it back what I
said no one needs to tell me anything
cuz it's not in my [ __ ] business oh
great and especially snitches ain't like
do you not watch the show page six like
always bordering and like crossing the
line of like inappropriate and unethical
journalism I agree like where do we draw
the line as a society I know and it's
like we put some as a show we put like a
lot of trust in page six even though
like I know for a fact they're not
always like they wrote untrue lies about
these were untrue lies that us like just
blatantly falsity and they were just
like our source to say like who the [ __ ]
are your sources cuz like I'm here to
tell you it's not [ __ ] true no like I
experienced my life what you are saying
is not true we're like so it confuses me
when I read stories that I really do try
space station that's like Daily Mail
also and TMZ jimsy saying I 8.2 million
followers which I wasn't upset about but
they also said that Trump tweeted about
me which was a joke and then they took
me and everybody it's like so little
like effort into like writing up news
stories like we're delivering these news
stories as if they're facts when like
nine times out of ten these like twenty
five-year-old journalists really just
got out of college I literally pulled it
out of their ass just so they could have
something to hand into their editor yeah
and we're like they have something but
it's not you see an absolute just
sprinkle little sources say when you
just start like the anti muckrakers
Union and only report on stories from
like legitimate news sources where we
feel as if the journalist has done
proper research we'll call it the anti
muckraker Society I'm so about that but
here's the issue because everyone was
posting in the group like about Jon Snow
like this story but are we not gonna
report on it just because we don't have
it from like what CNN even CNN like who
can you trust other than this host no
but it's so true it's just like they're
getting just as good apparently we're
wrong all the time
there are these news organizations that
just like the world's decided are legit
so they can write up straight-up
falsities and like we would believe it
because there's this like because
there's this social construct that like
CNN is like legit and like it probably
is but like how do we know that for sure
because it's CNN NBC tienen is really
the only news source you can truly trust
no agreed and but sometimes they can't
even so but I'm I just want to know did
you want to join my my company called
the anti McCray curse
Dumanis 100% I am so against muckraking
it's crazy
no and it's just so crazy I like they
say when you learn in school growing up
like isn't ever pertinent to like your
actual real life job but I feel as if
learning about yellow journalism and
muckraker ism was so pertinent to my
life's work that I wish I took an entire
course on muckraker ISM I agree and by
the way some could argue that we are
muckrakers
a hundred percent we're unbelievably
yellow in our journalism sometimes yeah
but I don't know I'm just starting away
think we're honest and when you know
where we should our website be anti
McGregor society calm or AMS calm I
think that's tough because AMS sounds
like a version of like PMS right but
anti-immigration or society leaves a lot
of space for you know uh typos so true I
may have a - an anti McGregor well you
know what would we be AMS edu because we
are an educational organization or are
we AMS gov mmm I don't think cob cuz we
don't have that you know I think we're a
dad organization oh we are Dorie we just
got to get our 501c3 status yeah I'll
work on it
I'll make the website I'll see what kind
of domains are available I'll use
Squarespace see if AMS comm is available
at AMS time that is billion
Squarespace will make it easy yeah we'll
design like a glam website where like
all the anti muckrakers can join
together and like well start a Facebook
group okay but seriously we use
Squarespace for many of our projects
including our chem trust website which
is still being worked on but I promise
it's coming I just really am working on
making it as premium as possible it's
like literally my life's work they don't
be ready for campus three yeah but X
where space you can find domains
websites online stores and marketing
tools from websites and online stores
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business they have a new
feature for email campaigns so you can
get the word out to all your toasty
friends say more sell more you can have
consistent content from your websites to
your email you can create a beautiful
website that will turn your cool idea
into a new website it'll showcase your
work you can blog or publish content
jackieo flow com sell products and
services of all kinds promote your
physical or online business and that's
an upcoming event or special project you
can own your domain promote your
business and Squarespace does this to
you by giving you beautiful templates to
create a world class design and powerful
ecommerce functionality lets you sell
online head to squarespace.com slash
toasts for a free trial and when you're
ready to launch use the offer code toast
and save
percent on your first purchase of a
website or domain love it yeah we had to
go through credit battle using
Squarespace to get camp toast calm it
was registered to I'm like an ID oh man
who literally had it like 30 years ago
I never used it but for a pretty penny
we got it nice and they helped us
negotiate
speaking of cam toast campers check the
Facebook group there's submerged details
everyone else merch goes on sale
tomorrow as the show wraps camp get your
camp merch it's like an premium I can't
stop wearing toast merch because like I
can't let the vibes go of cam
I'd like a bunch of fancy meetings today
and if I just like showed up in my March
I don't think like I'm wearing this
jumpsuit but I feel like wearing your
own merch it's like that is so [ __ ]
cool and who believes in your bread more
than you know and it's like I have
clothes I have a clothing line what are
you so true you know Iranian oh you be
like obliques your t-shirt I'll be like
the morning totes
know who makes sushi shirt meaning yeah
that's a great idea okay next story I'm
angry nailed it host Nicole Byer calls
out Netflix for [ __ ] up and
disrespectful advertising quote that's
her saying [ __ ] up and disrespectful
Netflix can't really say nailed it after
nailed it host Nicole Byer called out
the streaming service on Twitter on
Tuesday a twitter user named dill sauce
tweeted an image of a Netflix thumbnail
for the hit baking show and made some
comments about the people in the photo
dill sauce wrote quote I remember
reading somewhere that app Netflix puts
men on the thumbnails of show and movies
a lot but yo this is nuts
Nicole Byer is nailed it I love Wes and
chef Jacques but come on this is so
upsetting because the photo was just of
Wes in the studio and not Nicole Byer
who hosts the show Wes and Jojo both
have pivotal roles on the show with job
providing baking advice while West
brings out the Baker's had another
surprises but buyer on the other hand is
the hilarious host of the show who spews
out more NSFW comments than the bakers
know what to do with she took to Twitter
on Tuesday night to address the concerns
over the thumbnail image but deleted her
messages not long after in the since
deleted tweet she wrote quote if Netflix
didn't sign my checks and give me a huge
platform an opportunity to showcase my
comedy I would talk about how [ __ ] up
and disrespectful this is to me a black
woman also how black women are a lot of
times erased from many different
conversations
the comedian wrote in a subsequent tweet
I would talk about how it makes me know
my true value as the host of the show
where I work incredibly hard to elevate
the material given to me a lot of
moments people love our improvised she
continued I would
about how this is how this essentially
whitewashing for more views but they
sign my checks and I'm honestly so happy
and grateful to and for the show and no
sarcasm I love my job and mainly and I
wish to keep it so I'll be quiet
her last note red to be clear I know
there are some nails with and without my
face
this one just seems for lack of a better
word deliberate again I love my job I
love Nicole Byer I've been a fan of her
ever since girl coach it was truly just
the breakout star I'm so glad they love
her the world recognized her talent and
continues to give her opportunities
because she is so so hilarious but I do
have to say in terms of like as as far
as platforms go Netflix is like highly
inclusive and they're always just like
making shows for all different types of
people
and I would say like I know all the
networks and all the streaming services
they would be like last time we listed
someone who would deliberately whitewash
or be racist
then again they did this so like I don't
know if that's the case and they changed
it immediately she said in her between
that she spoke with an executive and
it's been handled
so do I know for sure or think for sure
that like this is a deliberate like
removal of Nicole Byers face because
she's a black woman because people only
watch the show literally for her no one
gives a [ __ ] about the making like it's
literally her show so I don't know if
that was the reasoning behind it just
because Netflix has a long history of
just being inclusive you know I agree
with what you're saying
um I will say though I'm a huge fan of
Nicole Byer I have passed nailed it on
my recommended shows on Netflix a
hundred times and I never known that she
was the host so I've never really yeah
this is the first time I'm finding out
that she's the host maybe I would have
[ __ ] watched it if I saw her in the
thumbnail totally feel like uh this
isn't like they're not doing a good job
of advertising her she said that she
says and what she said in her tweet like
which is so shady she's like I do a
great job of elevating the materials I'm
giving it's like this is a [ __ ]
baking show she's like I Barrett scripts
like that are firm or on just sure and
so there are so many meeting shows like
people love this show and because she is
the show apparently so now I have to
start watching it because no one [ __ ]
told me that Nicole Byer hosted it I
would watch that in the second I [ __ ]
love her and I don't get enough of her
am i well I love her I'm just like not
into really like baking shows which is
why I don't want you me neither but you
know what I'm always just watching
trailers throw things on Netflix because
I can't find something to watch so I'd
rather just watch nailed it
I got dead to me is I like honesty
should be calm nailed it with Nicole
Byer Oh completely also nailed it makes
it seem like it's a manicure show or a
home decor show I think it's a show
about where they go they like try and do
like viral baking trends and then they
[ __ ] them up and it's so funny
ya know but it's a terrible name for the
show yeah but I have this thing where
like I fall into depressions like I like
slumps after I finish the TV show like I
never really got my footing back after I
finished Desperate Housewives like cuz
no show in the world compares like it's
just it's not even worth watching
actually I know you probably wouldn't
even like it but if you wanted an
equally mesmerizing beautiful show Mad
Men then I know it's not your buy no
semi vibe but look and then I just
started getting to dead to me and I'm
like oh my god this like I had something
to look forward to when I got it and
then I finish it so now it's like I get
I take this stuff really seriously you
need to finish dynasty I've heard this I
said back up
I picked back up I'm like 10 episodes
behind I picked a couple yesterday wow
what a treat for you it is a treat um
also Margo came over and she was like
what's wrong with you teen day and I'm
like what do you mean she's like it's so
dull like Liz looks so pale and I'm like
what are you talking about and she like
she was totally right like I went on my
menu like I wasn't in vivid I was in
standard and I was like how the [ __ ] did
you realize because she's baratheon and
when she loves someone like she's knows
everything about them and they're [ __ ]
coloring yes she said I remember the
name was looked so beautiful in the
scene and like she looks washed out and
like are you a technician like how do
you [ __ ] know that she's somebody
else I mean either here maybe we won't
look washed out and we don't even know
maybe maybe if she [ __ ] showed up to
work back please love you
I do miss girlcode though that was a
great show it was a great show and guy
code you know I never really got into it
it was like girl code was good on to him
they like had to make guy code it was
first Oh God
I think we'd love to go home because it
was like girl stuff that we never liked
that you always want to talk about but
the guy said when they're talking about
boners it's like I don't know can't
relate you know I never watched guy code
like ever in my life and I think girl
code is more popular which is just like
so great for the patriarchy you know it
was so good but then like what happened
yeah I don't know they all really like
got famous on their own like Aquafina
Carly Aquilino on Nicole Byer onesa she
really was like the rising star of MTV
true interesting and I'll still never
get over the fact that I didn't know she
was
colin kaepernick which we found out last
week yeah I'm glad to see they're all
doing well you two ladies have a great
spring word and I do feel as if the show
was around now like maybe we would be
tapped for a pilot perhaps but you know
what I love the morning toast nobody
here I'm not trying to go anywhere next
story I teased it to claudia before the
show because alley racism was spotted
hanging out with a new man and i didn't
tell her it was because I wanted to get
her on a reaction
oh it's someone I know yes country
singer chase rice oh my god Aly Raisman
hung out with country singer chase rice
while cheering on the Boston Bruins
during Game one of the Stanley Cup final
apparently it's the Stanley Cup cool he
rocks prior to the puck drop on Monday
night a spy spotted Massachusetts native
a snitch you mean because we're reading
page six again should we call page
snitch yes
swish six message New York's a race been
holding hands with rice following his
setteth NHL's Stanley Cup final party at
Boston City Hall plaza while race min 25
in race 33 sad together to watch the
game a rep for the musician confirmed it
was just his friend I don't know I don't
hold it my friend may be there between
periods that's yeah between 28 day cycle
dimensional cycles race Minh or hockey
periods silkier race men who previously
did natural I'm Colton Underwood also
posed for photos this any such a stain
on her resume like Bachelor alum she's a
world-class Olympian it is a scene but
you know what he he took it he's as big
as he could be like he was a contestant
imagine he was just still contestant
like then he became the bachelor now
he's like a bona fide select but it
should have been former NFL player
culture another word like that's more
prestigious that's true um pose for
photos with NHL Deputy Commissioner Bill
day and NHL commissioner Gary Bettman
from inside TD Garden I love when we
read these random people's names it's
like I'm sure their daughters watching
totally fortunately for the Bruins race
Minh and rice brought them printing of
luck as Boston defeated the st. Louis
Blues wow we're also a sports show
because Boston won Game one a rep for a
ceman did not immediately return a
request for comment
if anyone's worried about me I'm [ __ ]
shipping this my ship is coming in
Colton and chase okay my ship is coming
in Colton and chase Allie and chase have
something to say I'm so here for it and
my dream my dream is for Aly Raisman to
be dating a country singer and we have
interviewed chase rice many times
and we keep telling that he needs to
Jade someone from the bathroom like he's
aiming higher and good for [ __ ] him
but I do wish like Aly Raisman would
start like dating stop dating town do
you know I mean it's like when : cheetah
Colton he was like a loser who got
ketone that I found like to have a job
and he was great and thing he made a
viral video ready he was very
philanthropic but like she was here and
he was here now chase price is
definitely a rising star but in terms of
just like Fame talent and success like
Aly Raisman again is here and he is here
like I feel like she has low self-esteem
or something because she keeps dating
like men lower than her and I do really
like she would take someone equal to
okay but who's equals here she's like
literally a [ __ ] Linnaean like she's
like Serena Williams like and Serena
Williams found someone appropriate
I agree like a billionaire tech mogul
who invented the worst platform ever a
great example Aly Raisman meets like
okay if it's gonna be a country's engine
like I'm sorry face it she needs Tim
McGraw like she needs someone on her
level and like I feel like maybe all the
relationships that she's like been in
aren't working out because like she has
low self-esteem or something because
like okay chase rice is definitely
up-and-coming but name me one cheese ray
song right okay so like I don't know
like nah I know he's he's married but
like okay okay like okay Brett young
would have been great like he just got
mad he just got married at his buddy's
pregnant I'm not saying that I want them
to break up but I'm saying like for
example like he's a rising star who's
like huge or like Brett Eldredge I think
he might be a little old for SpaceX is
33 oh yeah but chase race doesn't look
33 Brett Eldredge does now that I think
this would make a good couple but I just
want to give a shout out to Hunter Hayes
because he has been releasing some music
lately that's like I'm really worried
about it's deeply emotional first of all
we had dear God that was deeply
emotional but then he's but it's also
like a banger oh for sure and also it's
like I feel that you're about to be
emotional yes you like that he's like
wondering if he deserves love 100 hates
you deserve love then his next song is
called like heartbreak where it's like
he's grateful for every heartbreak
because it's gonna lead him to the next
person that he falls in love with and
like he's already excited to kiss this
next person it's like oh it's just um
it's a lot of hope
yeah I just and I love him and I just I
maybe he's right Crowley Riesman he was
dating someone I don't believe they're
dating anymore so his music
yeah she was a brother actually yeah so
she's watching like what happened girls
yeah and like you crushed him yeah
literally what's it you two
it's like she's Carrie Bradshaw and he's
Aiden like and then the Bernina makes
the face you know yeah that's us doing
it to you but there are some like
country singers Plus Aly Raisman who
need to be set up and I recommend
personally okay Cupid's new dating I
know me too
like if we were to fill out a profile
for Ali raids min it would be like
what's important to you country music
and that you're on my level OkCupid is
only dating app that finds you cemetery
music and a list right OkCupid is only
dating app that finds you someone based
on who you are and what you're into when
it comes to dating you know exactly what
you're what you like the OkCupid dating
app has lots of fun questions about the
things that you really care about so
it'll ask you like it would you date
someone who's not a feminist would you
know no yeah like but like but that's a
legitimate question like or it's like
would you do you support the ACLU like
they get really debug with the questions
and it's actually helpful cuz like you
could save a lot of [ __ ] time if it's
like you go on a date with some of
everything's talking about but then you
believe like they're pro-choice and
you're pro-life you know it's like
fundamental issues that like you would
never date someone or thier smoker so
it's like you get those questions out
right in the beginning and it makes it a
lot more helpful I feel yeah for sure
save your time you guys going on dates
is time consuming so OkCupid is only top
dating app that finds you something
based on who you are and what you're
into the app is tons of fun questions
it's um it's really just premium and I
feel like a lot of toasters have told me
about it which is when they decided to
partner with the show it made it seem
like an easy fit because I know a lot of
trousers who have met their husbands
boyfriends fiance's girlfriends
significant others on OkCupid dating up
I'm all about OkCupid dating app I met
my man's on an app about the app life
get on if you're not if you're single
and you're not on an app and I recommend
okay keep it standing up you're being
lazy you're not in the game yeah I agree
and people are saying where I need
someone like in this day and age it's on
OkCupid dating app like you sorry okay
so download the dating app if you meet
someone based off of our recommendation
like we go to heaven or something right
yes wouldn't we have to make three [ __ ]
offs um I'll say I think I can bargain
my way in with one like with one good
one you know yeah cuz how can you argue
with like one should ask where babies
for meat like I'm a baby
look you Brett breathes life into this
world right so like if you could just
give me one I'll take it from there so
we're
my way I would like updates on every
toaster who downloads though gay Cupid
dating app and find someone and that
gets married and stuff because like I
want credit yeah 100% unless people me
we we did this with not hard baby dude
with Olivia culpo we really need to find
someone perfect for Ally Raisman okay a
country singer who's established but
kind of young okay let me go to my
playlist yeah because uh also who's hot
cuz like she's beautiful
okay um there are a lot of them are
really married you know right that's
nice about for traffic that's right and
the ones who are up-and-coming like
won't be good enough for you right her
that's true John party no okay someone
from Lancome the old dominion guy oh
yeah even though he's not famous enough
like on his phone I feel and sound like
his schedule is just as busy like Ally
Raisman
like chase rice would just like have to
do everything with Aly Raisman I feel
like he doesn't have that busy of
schedule Chris Young major cutie no yeah
but it's this evening as chase right
right Oh
I mean he's dating someone but Cole
Swindell yeah yeah but we stand him and
Barbie and we don't want them to break
up no we do not okay I'm still I'm still
looking but better like someone in the
music industry like in the music
industry is tawdry as hell you know they
came Brown but he's married yeah and I
think she's pregnant and they're like
really [ __ ] cute right exactly
Mitchell Tenpenny it's so funny like
really truly all the men in country
music like make nice lives for
themselves right so it's like there's
not and so she Lauren Burnham's in labor
no I didn't see I saw a picture of her
in a hospital gown yes she they said
it's time Wow
cute cute I love them I just want them
to have like so many babies and like a
lifetime of happiness and just like get
that answer their money and you what you
got to do it seems like that they're
well on their way yeah their house is so
cute too
well speak I had a wonderful segue which
was speaking of OkCupid dating app and
people who are now single Mackenzie
Bezos will donate half her fortune to
charity
Mackenzie Bezos is the latest
billionaire to sign the Giving Pledge
committing at least half of her 35
billion dollar fortune to charity
Bezos joins Mark Zuckerberg Richard
Branson and Robert F Smith on the list
of donors to Bill Gates and Warren
Buffett's initiative in a letter
published by The Giving Pledge Bezos
McCann
the rights of having a quote
disproportionate amount of money to
share and credits quote an infinite
series of influences and lucky breaks we
can never fully understand for her
wealth bezos's signature alongside hedge
fund billionaires David Harding and Paul
Tudor Jones Brian Armstrong chief
executives of cryptocurrency company
coinbase
and whatsapp's co-founder Brian Acton
brings the total signatories to more
than 200 people The Giving Pledge began
in August 2010 when 40 of America's
wealthiest individuals made a commitment
to give more than half of their wealth
away the scheme is described as quote an
open invitation for billionaires to
publicly dedicate the majority of their
wealth to philanthropy you know what
Mackenzie doesn't list any particular
cause she writes quote my approach to
philanthropy will continue to be
thoughtful it will take time and effort
and care but I won't wait and I will
keep at it until the safe is empty like
if you think when I first saw that I
like rolled my eyes I'm like I'm a fan
but if I had that much money just keep
it from yourself but now that I think
about it it's like what does
I don't like thirty six billion dollars
which is her current fortune like you
literally couldn't spend that in a
lifetime so like it really is so stupid
to have that much money and I do applaud
her for giving it right like as long as
you keep enough that still makes you
super rich and you never have to worry
about money like for your kids your kids
kids and your kids kids kids um I do
think this is quite you know uh heroic
yeah it's it's a cool thing the giving
tree' that's what they should call it
The Giving Pledge where yeah a lot of
billionaires have pledged short because
like and they literally have more money
than they physically can spend in the in
their years on earth right and then it
becomes such a waste just my my thing is
I just would like to know where it's
going because it seems like there's just
like so much poverty in the world like
so much you know disparities like oh
just these just these ten billionaires
who have decided to sign over half their
fortunes forty forty that's that
literally is enough money to fix the
world's problem exactly why is there so
poverty that's my question so I would
just if I could just see some receipts
see some schools being billed like a
children who have directly benefited
like I really we just I mean this is the
first I've heard of this week mentioned
it's not the first I've heard it but I'm
really just curious like this is so much
money and I would love to see what
you're doing quite like literally just
Mackenzie Bezos is like half could feed
an entire nation for years to come so
it's like why are there still so many
you know world worldly problems yeah I
just
we just like to see like make a video
you know like a highlight reel Camco
style of what you're doing with it yeah
they need a promotional video yeah
that's all I'm saying but I think maybe
I would donate half of my portion they
could get like a thousand dollars yeah
this is super quilt oh good for her
yeah good fern I just feel like the
world hates her like even though she's
truly the victim really I don't need her
because I just overnight she became the
wealthiest I feel like she's like she
overtaking the wealthiest woman but she
also was like so embarrassing oh in
front of the world like her husband
sending those texts and like I just want
they were sellout with you there and
there were some texts like that were
just horrified some sources snitcher
that was just like really sad and this
is the least he can do for her and now
she gets to give back so like her
insides are feeling good and you know
her bank accounts feeling good ya know
she seems a good person I'm how she
become friends with her so maybe she'll
join a dead rest of her fortune to us
right I'm happy for her no even if I can
she's like so snatched she's gonna be
fine yeah she looks are ya know she's
really pretty
she'll be fine yeah not only today but
she's got billions in the bank and
billions donated to philanthropy she'll
be just fine I wonder if she'll meet
someone yeah this seems to be a common
theme someone mentioned I'm sure where
we have all these like great
bachelorettes and like we want to set
them up with people and there's just not
enough great guy thought that that is
the world back to the world it's like
even the toasters actually that's not
well for the most part like when a meto
service at my shows or even I cam toast
like they have such a good stable
marriages like I think the husbands come
they don't want to be in my show they're
just so supportive they take pictures of
their wives they like don't make fun of
their wives for like getting drunk and
hanging out with their internet friends
I've actually really found that the
toasters have like really good
relationship I agree you know but that's
not to be said they just most of the
single girls that I know are [ __ ]
quality girls who like literally there
isn't a guy within a thousand miles that
would be good enough for them and that's
just a problem the world has there's a
shortage of eligible quality Ben Nye no
just no just men the women are good yeah
that's what lesbians have it so good
totes well now that's the past five
Beverly Hills
talking I did even after I wrapped my
patreon video at 11 o'clock I had to
turn
Hills because I had some morning show
take it seriously um it was the first
episode that Lisa Vanderpump was not in
for a second right and I was wondering
why I loved it so much I loved it for a
million reasons I loved that Lisa
Vanderpump wasn't it I love at the end
of the Hawaii trip everyone started to
turn on Camille and really understand
the two-faced [ __ ] that she is right I
love to read and PK's a costume I love
Lisa Rinna's costume and I absolutely
adored Denise Richards coming in getting
controversial and defending her friend
Lisa Rinna
I completely forgot that they're best
friends like that no well I thought that
they just brought jennice in that way
and then like that lady they let that
whole storyline fizzle them actually
being friends but they are no like they
talk like you know she confides in her
and and she said that whole bunny thing
like really hurt Lisa Rinna and I
believe that I believe it - we've never
seen any super in a cry so much she ate
her own snot she tear over look when
you're eating your own Cheers
that's pain no that's really really pain
like you can't you can fake a tear you
can't fake a stream that you can't keep
out of your mouth and snot - yeah she of
course she was so heard that's a [ __ ]
got like that was so good enough for
daddy bunny like as much as it's a joke
like that's a really serious thing in
her family like all the kids have it and
by the way I have one someone bought me
one is the greatest thing know I can
they meet problem my brother Joe oh yeah
so yes I loved Denise Richards just
getting involved and coming for Kyle to
like Kyle's usually on the right side of
history and but in scenarios like this
she gets way because Kim is her sister
and she should she defend her sister
finally unfortunately like she has to
always defend the paymon like Kim's just
like so sometimes hard to defend
yeah but like if we're on a show
together I don't care what you do I have
your back I love the pepper - you're
going toe to toe with researchers I'm
sorry Denise I gotta get my sister
others later I loved that they filmed
and aired every single person getting
scared by that guy I'm so funny it was
so funny and people like there wasn't a
lot of drama in this episode and I just
really like still enjoyed it and I can't
stress that enough I'd be like Bravo
editors and producers think that there
has to be that crazy flipping table
drama for a season to be good but no
like I really enjoyed this I really
enjoyed
and the drama that was was squashed
really quickly and that's also nice too
when they have that hugging moment like
it was just like in New Jersey when the
Marge and to defend of her when added at
that table like really hello the ballot
and then immediately she apologized and
it's like that's what I like to see I
want to see if I but I also I don't want
the pit going into next week yeah I
really know like I do not [ __ ] with Kim
Richards at all like I used to love
Ryder died for her like when her and
Brandi were like best friends and like
brandi was actually being really good
for her friendship like I loved it
I do not [ __ ] with her whatsoever I hate
seeing her back on my TV screen I think
it's bad for her mental health it's just
really great why she why she absolutely
never road for her ever like I just did
not understand her appeal like and there
were so many times when she was truly
troubled and it's like it's making a
spectacle of it and putting it on TV
it's like this is doing nothing for no
one and even after she was like
shoplifting at Target and all that stuff
in like she's back on the show like it
just never like felt right to me and it
wasn't enjoyable it's not fun to watch
her fight with someone because it's like
not a fair fight ya know what I mean
yeah so I never rode for her I did not
enjoy seeing her back I just don't think
the shot was the right place for her no
me neither and I just I could really
live without her yeah everyone's
costumes were so premium Kyle looked
amazing I mean shucks I wish that at any
age I could look like that but she looks
stellar Lisa Rinna's was hilarious I was
a little disappointed by Erika Jaynes
like too bad I guess when you're Erika
Jayne it's like every day every day is
Halloween so what are you gonna do
that's gonna like break like she doesn't
even I don't know I was disappointed but
it was like what could she have done
yeah Eddie at Eddie and Edwin like was
basic but really well done really well
done uh what's her name Denise and her
man's super Keys super trick she looks
like the wives
totally except she was like so beautiful
and then during the PK one for me like
hey miss Connelly just just pk hey miss
Carl was iconic but then she was his cat
she'll pet and he that cat is everywhere
it's on every bag so they really went
hand in
and it was it was iconic and she looked
so fun she's so far and I just love her
me too
like I'm here for her permanently Herman
he had a nightly Davidson effect on me
I am permanently here for her she brings
everything she's got to the show except
for her lawsuits I read an engine I
don't want to hear about them I read a
very interesting like theory about how
Denise Richards is really like the
reincarnated ghost of Eileen Davidson
because the go 16 just passed right at
first when eileen game on em and Denise
came on you I didn't really understand
like all the hype like this famous
person like whatever and you weren't
really here for it but then they turn
into like this pillar of just common
sense and like logic and you find
yourself just siding with them just for
the pure fact that they're making so
much sense Wow isn't that a really good
command she's the ghost I have to have a
shout-out it's to this guy I follow on
Twitter he's a writer for The Daily Mail
and I'm like New Zealand and he does so
much housewives like recaps but he also
does like kpop which I don't really
understand um his name is Jacques and I
really enjoy it that's exactly what it
is because now it's like whatever side
Denise is on like I feel myself
gravitating towards and also like turn
to read have a really real friendship
and that says to me that like jury is
like a good a good girl yeah I feel like
the Housewives of Beverly Hills
specifically well I don't think that the
entire cast like starts out as friends I
think that they really end up being
really good friends with each other like
in in certain cities you can really tell
when like the group goes back like
Atlanta like they have been friends for
a long time or you can really tell like
in a negative way like some of the
seasons of Jersey where like they just
saw a bunch of women together and try
and make them friends yeah but I think
in Beverly Hills it's a combination of a
lot of them knowing each other for a
long time like Lisa engine ease but then
also them just throwing random women in
a group together but then actually like
starting real friendships like I mean
Kyle yeah now I'm looking like Joey and
Denise yes I agree because also like the
women that they throw in it's like they
want to be friends with me like they
probably ever met her before and now
they're excited that like they're
different when they throw in like a
Carlton Gebbia it's not gonna work yeah
but I just am really liking the
friendships being formed and watching
them evolved yeah the bar for bringing
in new Beverly Hills housewives is
actually really hot they either have to
be an established celebrity like a
familial connection like Teddy or Erica
Jane right but they went through a real
lull when they were bringing in Kathryn
Edwards really trying to make like that
oh geez
Eden Sassoon um Joyce like they really
went through like a lot of rich ladies
to get to the gold mine that they now
currently have agreed next week Brandi
comes back and it could with Denise how
do you think they know each other I
don't know I guess they're friends maybe
they know through like Eddie maybe they
just became crazy back in the day but
I'm so fun I feel like Denise is is
really not judgmental yeah Denise is
poised and put together but she can
throw down and costume me go it's just
like any of them and all the ladies you
should really judge Brandi for how much
she drank but I really feel like Denise
if Brandi would ever come back like
Denise would be a great friend for like
she's really fun she's but she's still
like put together but she's not
judgmental she's not judgmental she's
also not sensitive yeah the hand job the
happy ending stuff is like she knew that
they were being mean she didn't care
yeah and so like when Brandi gets to her
place of like teasing her friends and
like when she sucks at Lisa Vanderpump
in the face and Lisa Bennett was like oh
yeah like but it was like not really a
huge deal like Denise wouldn't have been
phased by that yeah where when Brandi
threw the wine she was thrown aback a
hundred percent but a normal person that
was I mean that was a late I mean this
is who she is and know your boundaries
with Eileen yes yes but denise i'm
loving denise I'm loving this so I'm
excited for Brenda next week but I'm
also really excited for what looks to be
the coming for Camille Grammer because
she needs to be called out and also how
big of a loser is she like the day after
your wedding you're so thirsty to film
because you never get airtime because
you're not a real housewife you would
ditch your husband Lori the morning
after your [ __ ] wedding and go have
lunch with people you don't even know I
can't think about is that she went there
fact that she invited all those women to
her wedding which it was such a small
wedding and really she's not friends
with any of them except she's kind of
friends of Kyle Kyle was her [ __ ]
bridesmaid like that's how thirsty she
is she spent her entire wedding weekend
or engagement party her wedding or the
bridal shower of everything
she spent everything with these ladies
who aren't even her friends ya know it
was it was really weird for losery like
it is the definition loser
yeah like I couldn't even see my own
family after the day after my wedding
just like what's your what are you doing
I'm gonna be yellow dress agreed like
we're all ready for this filming oh yeah
look she brought wardrobe not even for
her wedding for the filming yeah I I was
not here for it and then someone should
tell dirty like what was said about her
she didn't ask yep everything want to be
embarrassed in front of all of the women
she would have brought up Rena probably
wouldn't have said it in front of all
the women like Janna is not like that
because then it would have been like an
elephant in the room like your
financials are confusing they are but I
don't care I mean you live in a house I
do you still then yeah you rent um I
don't care yeah I don't care like I know
I'm like I just I want all to work out
for her I want her to win her loss like
I just need this chapter to be closed of
like the questionable like finances of
it all yeah I'm really enjoying this
like a lull we have in Bravo shows
because Vanderpump rules is off and it's
just we only have Beverly Hills New York
and southern charm every weekend it's
just like it's a perfect amount there
was a while where Vanderpump was on
Atlanta was on like it was just a lot
for me ya know last night I was like I
thought southern charm was also on and
Joe is so grateful when I saw a
commercial that it was on on Wednesday
cuz I just couldn't have done it no I
know like and then that I'll watch
tonight and that's that New York like so
nice so nice and I have to watch dynasty
and I think I wonder what else I miss
it's just a good schedule like I'm
enjoying it
yeah I mean it's summertime so we have
less time yeah I need you bring
breakfast summer by Bravo commercials
where they all like we're in the circus
well now they have that thing with like
summer house and Stassi and Beau that is
so weird what is that I never I haven't
seen the faux commercial yet but it's a
Pepsi commercial oh and now they're
doing all these have you seen like the
Tresemme the southern charm tres may add
either doing ads for other but it's
written really it's brilliant and I
enjoy most of them but I mean not the
one where jaronda and Sonja went to go
see a great tale of female friendship oh
my god that was hard that was horrible
we're not the one where Dorinda and
Luann's like daughters and them saw mama
me Oh terrible but you bring up just one
more not branded summer vibrato
commercial yeah I wonder where they
stopped doing it yeah so what's about
the wind she's like posing from Sag
Harbor for Memorial Day but like I
thought she was in jail
maybe she got arrested but then ones out
on bail I haven't see I haven't seen one
update since since we weren't ported on
it yeah weird are you filming now I've
also only been looking at the hash tag
cam toast and hash a Jackie O flat Flo
hashtag so I don't know you're - I'm so
unless she's using my presets I wouldn't
see it I'm just too consumed with my own
brand to think of anything else no
totally even last night I didn't know
how I was gonna pivot from like watching
all the videos from camp toes because I
had other people send me their videos
too
right in that right mom apologize
because I wanted it to be not just from
like our perspectives um I really didn't
know how it's gonna be interested in
like Bravo I I figured it out away but
uh it's hard to like stop watching camp
content and like go watch some TV which
is so crazy which is exactly what I'm
gonna do this weekend because it's my
first weekend home since February and I
just I'm too excited like I don't want
to make any plans Wow well I have the
opposite weekend of no as you I have the
most hyped up weekend of my life I've
been waiting five years for this weekend
me my friends and I like we've been
talking about this weekend for five
years now so I'm like honestly really
[ __ ] scared that like just
something's Crazy's gonna happen like
I'm gonna get a tattoo that says Colgate
on my butt oh that cool like that's
what's like that's how crazy things
could get so jackie has her five year
college reunion and our studios closed
on Friday so there's no show Friday but
Thursday tomorrow well tomorrow is our
last show of the week which is pretty
big news
oh yeah which we can should we say now
um well the news is gonna be there's
gonna be more to the news but I think we
get to share the first piece of the news
because we it's pertinent it is
pertinent because tomorrow will be the
first episode of our nicer let me figure
out how I want to say this tomorrow
we are releasing a new podcast that is a
part of our TNN our toast news network
it is not a show that has mean we are
Jackie it is Ben's show this little job
it's called this ship it you've heard of
it
he's heard of it he's been hyping it up
for a while follow the ship it's on
Instagram
sh t VI TZ it'll be up on iTunes
tomorrow first episode it's not the NBA
Jack all of our sporty Steen's anyone
who gives a [ __ ] about basketball tell
your husband's your boyfriend's anyone
who cares
this fits we are going to be releasing a
few shows that we think are Seanie and
toasty over the next couple months if
you have any recommendations actually of
people who you think are toasty that are
like kind of so growing or still you
know developing their audience we would
love to you know hear about it we've a
few shows in development this is the
first of all out we're so excited tell
your husband's boyfriends dad
girlfriends sisters basketball and also
people who don't understand your love
for the toast because if you get them
into a podcast then they'll understand
while you're going to the mountain
seeing out with your internet friends so
it is Ben and his two friends Jack and
Victor they all went to high school
together Jack and Victor and then when
they get together like they're they're
us but like in the most annoying like
boyish way and it's so funny they have
their own language too like I literally
don't even know what they're talking
about half the time and they are like
ride-or-die for sports like they are
obsessed with all things sports they're
gonna be covering all sports but now
since it's an NBA Finals or the draft or
whatever we're doing basketball only it
is an official TNN show and we are
really excited about it so we will be
posting links make sure to follow along
do that and thanks for checking along
with us that tells she wrote we will see
you tomorrow have a great day
you